[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday december 16th
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and welcome to our
christmas special
on the show andrew neal and diane abbott
spent years together presenting the
bbc's this week they'll be reunited on
spectator tv as we review 2021
withdrawal from afghanistan the occus
alliance looming conflict with russia
over ukraine and the threat of china to
taiwan stories about conflict and
defense have been prominent this year
andrew will interview the defense
secretary ben wallace
the royals have been one of your
favorite topics this year nearly one and
a half million of you watch freddie and
rod talk about harry and megan's
departure from the family in march
they'll be back on the show to give us
an overview of a tumultuous year for the
palace
christmas in a pandemic is bad but peter
hitchens reminds us that it could always
be worse
detailing what the festive period in the
ussr was like for our magazine's
christmas issue he'll tell cindy all
about it and will be joined by the
historian robert service who says he
once spent the most miserable christmas
of his life in leningrad
and finally struggling for a last-minute
christmas gift spectator contributors
phillip henscher and ascenda maxtone
graham give cindy their books of the
year
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv remember to subscribe to
our youtube channel just click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode and we've got
a special christmas offer for you for
just 12 pounds you can get 12 weeks of
the magazine in print and online and a
bottle of tattensure champagne usually
worth 42 pounds this offer is as good as
it gets just go to spectator dot co dot
uk forward slash cheers to take it up
this year started with the storming of
the capitol building in dc
matt hancock handed in his resignation
as health secretary
gas prices then soared and now we're
dealing with the new omicron variant to
help us make sense of the last 12 months
i'm joined by andrew neal and diane
abbott
andrew let's focus in on the uk in
january the tories were 20 points ahead
in the polls today they're eight points
behind what's gone wrong
uh i think it could be summed up in two
words boris johnson
that's what's gone wrong
i think people have just uh tired of
your stick
it's a bit wearing now he got away with
it for a long while
uh and people said that's just boris we
can put up with him
doing that's the way he is and so on
and i think that over time it's just
began to great and the longer the
pandemic's going on i think the more our
sense of humor has been tested
and we're just looking for some
competence now and some sense of
direction and
of where the country's going and we're
not getting any of that at all i think
that uh shares and boris johnson are
collapsing and i'm not quite sure how
the market will be pumped up i think
once
people turn against them it'll be quite
a brutal turning and quite a quicker
turning uh than you might think
diane i suspect you like andrew's answer
um i don't want to be harsh about boris
johnson but his main issue
yes i do really
yes you do
his main problem is he's a congenital
liar
and some of his immediate problems right
now are to do with him not being able to
tell the truth i mean he lied about the
christmas party whereas in a way if he'd
been more honest from the beginning it
just wouldn't have gotten worse and
worse for him you went from one
christmas party to i can't remember now
half a dozen and poor allegra stratton
having you know being thrown overboard
he lied about coronavirus saying it we
were over the worst and he just doesn't
tell the truth and it's catching up with
it
i think it it the problem with
not telling the truth or to be polite
economical was the truth
is it believe the accepted phrase
is that it also highlights that the
trouble the government is in is almost
entirely self-inflicted i mean i've
covered governments over the years they
all get into trouble it's the nature of
government but they usually get into
trouble because of uh their policies are
wrong margaret thatcher and the poll tax
or tony blair and iraq or because the
country faces huge inflation and
unemployment or a
quadrupling of oil prices and so on
that's how governments get into trouble
this government's not in trouble because
of any of that it's in trouble because
of self-inflicted inability to tell the
truth on simple things and they are
simple things and under the grand scheme
they may not matter but as we come to
the end of almost a second year of this
pandemic
i think the british people do want to
know that all the rules and regulations
we have to follow are being followed by
everybody and the evidence recently has
been that they haven't been followed by
everybody and i think that you know this
is a country which even during the
second world war the royal family lived
off the same rations as my mom and dad
lived off
we expect account because we are quite
an unequal country we do expect fair
play and proper behavior of our public
figures and we've not been getting it
well given there's such agreement
between the two of you to kick off this
segment i'm going to have to play
devil's advocate diane perhaps one of
the frustrations isn't simply at boris
johnson but at the entire attitude of
whitehall the labour party included that
consistently whether it's kia stamina
not wearing a mask in an indoor space
over the summer when he was supposed to
be or boris johnson's team clearly
having a party in number 10
it just always feels like there's one
rule for people in westminster and
another role for the rest of the nation
well
there's an issue
about westminster versus the real world
but i'm sorry to say that for better or
worse what a stuck is that there's one
rule for the tories
and another set of rules for everybody
else and you see what that does is it
plays to people's
worst tribal feelings about the tourists
and it's particularly dangerous for the
tourists in relation to the red wall
seats which you know boris
helped people win they had a majority of
80. now they have a majority of 18 now
but
the people in the red wall seats who
voted tory for the first time this
business about one of the tories another
world for the rest of us
really resonates at a really profound
level that's why it's so damaging
but i think that boris johnson's also
been lucky to be up against this labour
opposition
i mean if he'd been up against a really
effective opposition the polls were
returned a long time ago but kierstarma
who seems to me to be i don't know him
very well i've interviewed him he seems
to me to be a decent uh
enough chat uh he hasn't had that much
cut through uh and so mr johnson despite
stumbling from
self-enforced error to self-enforced
error to u-turn to cover-ups and so on
there's been very little cut through by
the labour party uh to capitalize on
that until
the past couple of weeks until the year
has become to an end and i think that's
why the past couple of weeks have been a
watershed uh mr starmer is now
consistently ahead with his labour party
in the polls not by a lot but he's ahead
and if that labor lead stays
into january february march and into
april
the reason why boris johnson is leader
of the conservative party he's a winner
he won brexit he won london twice he won
the general election of 2018. the reason
why he's leader will no longer be there
and i think that's when it will be the
most dangerous time for boris johnson
but dianne kiyosama isn't ahead in the
polls because labor are winning the
hearts and minds of voters he's ahead
because people are frustrated with boris
johnson it's not the ideal set of
circumstances for the labor party well
in politics you take the circumstances
that you can get i don't know if you've
noticed
but but kyr although he's been critical
and so on keeps stopping short of
calling on boris johnson to resign now
there are even some tory mps
who on the choir would like boris
johnson to resign but the people around
here seem to think that they want to
damage but they don't
want to actually see him resign because
they think
he would be a much
easier leader to defeat
in the forthcoming general election
2023-2024
now whether that's right or not i don't
know but you you have to be concerned if
you're
not a tourist supporter how much damage
boris can do
if we just
don't
make him resign or don't insist that he
resigns for purely strategic reasons
but
all oppositions can make prime ministers
resign but he's not prime ministers of
the majority of 80. i mean if i was keen
to start i might call on him to resign
but i wouldn't want him to resign the
way things are going at the moment he's
become a liability for the children
yeah i think so i would want i would
want him to hold on i think there's a
bigger decision for those tories who now
think that boris johnson is a liability
because they they only have one shot in
their locker if they trigger a
confidence motion
and they lose it he's there for at least
another year
so they've got to be sure they've got
the votes and i'm pretty certain at the
moment they don't have the votes to do
it which is why i don't think there'll
be any kind of leadership challenge
before the spring at the earliest if
then
diane let me ask you quickly if the
labour party wants boris johnson to stay
in office because they think he's easier
opposition who's labor afraid of in the
tory party
well almost anybody else what i was
trying to say is there is a by-election
this week the north shropshire
by-election now i think it's extremely
like the tourists will lose because they
have such a
a huge majority they might lose they
might lose
yeah but what i'm saying is if they were
to lose
that might be what precipitates a vote
of confidence because
tory mps would be frightened people in
more marginal seats people as i say in
seats which the tories won in 2019 the
so-called red wall seats they'll begin
to panic and as we know
if the tourists really think you're a
vote lisa if they really turn against
you as they turn against margaret
thatcher they can be extremely ruthless
well let's we only have a few minutes
left so let's get some kova chat in here
too because andrew the year started off
in january with the vaccines arriving
people quite willing to stay in lockdown
so we could get jabs into arms even
avoiding park benches because we weren't
legally allowed to sit on them with
somebody else for months into the new
year the year is ending and whilst we're
in a different position certainly with
vaccines antivirals and the rest of it
the talk is once again about lockdown
well it is deja vu all over again and i
think people are beginning to despair
the longevity of this pandemic and we
should be surprised the spanish flew at
the end of the first world war
went on for several years too but it
always seems that just as we think we're
getting on top of it whether it was
lockdowns or the rollout of the vaccine
which was a great success uh
or whether it is now this rollout of the
booster jab or further lockdowns
we never seem to come to an end it
always seems just to be
one more problem around the corner and i
think that is making people fractious i
think they're despairing a bit the
prospects of another restricted chris
christmas is making the public mood
quite slowly perfectly under uh stand
that
i think at the end
the vaccines are still to get out of
jail card here i mean the important
thing is that for this new variant
the booster jab gives about 70 75
immunity and it certainly substantially
reduces the chances of hospitalizations
or of death and what we've seen in the
course of this year depressing as it's
been has been lesser reliance on
lockdowns and physical restrictions
which you will remember kate were very
much in place at this time last year in
the run-up to christmas
now some restrictions but not huge
restrictions
and more emphasis on getting these
booster vaccines out
that is progress of a sort it's
encouraging it's just passing slow
diane the labour party says that it
would go further with restrictions it's
not the merriest message to be sending
at christmas time well i think the main
thing is um the government's to have new
data on infections and deaths and so
forth at the end of this
week and i think if that new data
is very bad we may be seeing lockdown
again i noticed that boris whenever he's
in when he's like wherever he's
interviewed refuses to say that there
won't be
any lockdown
i just think no government can say there
won't be another lockdown because
we learn new things every day and we
don't really know what's going on the
the some early evidence suggests that
this new variant the south african
variant omnicrom uh is that it it
spreads much more easily
but it may not be nearly so serious so
dangerous
that's the early evidence a doctor from
south africa who has been at the head of
this writing in the papers this morning
about that but we don't know yet
and it could be with all the data as
diane's talking about comes in could be
that it not releases spread easily it
could be very serious
we just don't know so i think
governments have to keep their options
open but i do think
that bit by bit and it's not just uh in
britain it's also true in america we're
moving away from an emphasis on
lockdowns because we've come almost to
the end of the road on that and we see
what it's doing to the economy it grew
by only 0.1 in october
we're not zooming out of this with great
growth on to putting all our eggs into
the vaccine basket and
i think that is probably the right way
indeed maybe the only way to go now
i wish i had another hour with both of
you but sadly i only have a matter of
minutes so to finish off i want to know
what your moments of 2021 were diane
i'll start with you
well i think so many moments to choose
from but i would choose boris's speech
to the cbi where he spoke about peppa
pig i've never seen a panic
a british prime minister refer to a
cartoon character in a major speech like
that only boris would do such a thing
only boris
could get away with such a thing but it
may just be
as we approach the end of the year that
boris is running out of road we will see
thanks diane andrew
uh i've got two international one
was the uh withdrawal the uh scuttling
from afghanistan i don't think any of us
will ever forget these pictures people
falling out of
the wheelbases on planes trying to get
through the taliban i mean that was a
horrendous departure the issue was not
the departure itself it was the manner
in which president biden chose to do it
and i think that will haunt the biden
administration haunt the west uh for the
foreseeable future and it is already
having a huge impact on the attitude of
the totalitarians and the authoritarians
from moscow to beijing
my
this image that struck most in my mind
domestically
was the queen
sitting alone at prince philip's funeral
uh because of covert restrictions it was
a heartbreaking picture we knew
how close and how much
uh the queen depended on prince feather
but it
it it wasn't just about the queen over
the death of prince philip it was about
what this pandemic had done too
done to us as a country
that even if even the queen
cannot have someone sitting beside her
at the her loneliest most aggrieved
moment
uh you could see what it was doing to
the rest of us too and i think it it
summed up what so many people
have had to go through during this
terrible pandemic
thank you andrew and thank you diane
looking forward to having you both back
together on spectator tv soon
defense and conflict have been one of
the biggest themes of the year as andrew
just mentioned britain and america
withdrew shambolically from afghanistan
the french fumed about the new ocos
alliance and military chiefs warned
about a russian invasion of ukraine
on tuesday andrew neal spoke to the
defense secretary ben wallace
secretary of state the united states has
warned its allies
that russia is preparing to invade
ukraine
do you share that assessment yes we do
we share the fact that the russian
military buildup
uh is for a purpose um
we
aren't
uh sure that he hasn't desperately made
a decision but nevertheless his actions
and his military preparations indicate
that way and i think if you couple that
with the article he wrote in july of
this year about
his vision of where ukraine belongs in
russia
i think we should all be worried
it's clear he's mounted the capability
175 000 troops 100 tactical battalion
groups uh on the border and many other
uh forces too
do we have any idea what it is that
would trigger a decision that would he's
got the capability what would then make
him deploy that capability well i think
that's what the sort of debate is in the
west at the moment which is how much of
this is an if
and how much of it is a when and you
know i i would point your viewers to the
article he wrote in july which is you
know not to be taken in by the sort of
russian playbook i think as uh as
secretary of state blinking had said
which you know the russian playbook is
i'm surrounded by nato nato is a
threatening organization when in fact
the reality is we know nato is a
defensive organization
only 1 16th of the russian border
is neighbors a nato state
so
but you know he's actually off the view
that really ukraine belongs to russia he
made that clear really in 2014 when he
effectively went into crimea
and went into the donbass and i think i
think that is why
uh there's a current debate in the west
which is you know is there a game you
know is the game afoot has the chess
game started
and if it has uh will it be checkmate in
three moves or will will it be a play to
a stalemate i mean i think that that's
what we're looking at and if you look at
the actions even the massing of forces
the 2014 the article in july
i think that's why we all have a genuine
cause of concern
but you you can understand that why the
kremlin has a strong interest in in a
non-aligned ukraine it doesn't want it
to be part of nato seems to me there's
very little prospect of being part of
nato in the foreseeable futures why
don't we de-escalate matters by just
making it clear ukraine
is not joining nato well i think it's
because what actually threatens russia
are nato's values it's not nato's
military force it's nato's values and
that isn't going to go away i mean
you know
you could argue that if this was ukraine
wishing to join the eu
as opposed to nato which you know a
number of countries in europe have
expressed those views russia has often
taken the equally heavy hand towards
that they don't
wish to choose
or want their countries near their
sphere of influence as they'd call them
to choose a different set of values and
i think that's that's really what is uh
to some extent at play here i think i
think you're right about the likelihood
of ukraine joining nato so why not just
say it if it would if it ris if it
raises the chances of avoiding an
invasion if it helps to de-escalate
why not just say it well i think first
of all because our values are about
respecting sovereign countries right i
mean wanting to be part of something and
being part of something are are two
different issues um you know if if you
know nato by its very definition has
always been open to membership of other
applicants doesn't mean to say they're
successful but fundamentally
uh you know it is a sovereign state free
to wish
to express its wishes and and actually
don't just ask nato members you know
reference the president of finland's
recent statements and statements coming
out of sweden two countries that are not
planning to be part of nato not
expressed a wish to be part of nato but
nevertheless very very
strong in defending their right to
choose their future so i think that's
that's understandable i understand that
but neither finland nor
the sweden of 175 000 russian troops uh
on their border uh and
if the choices between recognizing what
we both agreed is not going to happen
that ukraine is not going to join nato
if the choices is conceding that or 175
000 troops heading towards kiev
i mean what would you rather have
well i'd rather russia respected uh
andrew sovereign
nations and i you know i mean is
what you're sort of suggesting is that
nato
uh backs down from its values and its
articles effectively which have been in
existence since 19 you know 70 years
really uh because somebody has mass
troops on the border i mean i think that
is that's a that's a slippery slope
of what happens you know what happens
you know there are very very
considerable number of russian troops
stationed on estonia's borders and and
latvia's borders but that's part of nato
yes but but the the point is
uh you know to suggest that nato uh
moves away from its own values
uh of open membership
or or allowing people to apply based on
their sovereign will
you know isn't much different from what
happens when those
forces massed on estonian border
nato is asked to again reconsider its
values because there's a whole lot of
forces on its borders i think what we
have to be is clear here
that nato
stands for something nato has always had
a a membership policy that you can apply
through the process they're not the only
states that that have explored that
it doesn't mean to say it's going to
happen anytime soon it may not happen at
all you know i think france and germany
back in 2008 were very clear about it
but also you know let's not play into
the playbook here of the kremlin nato is
a defensive organization that's its
articles we're not an offensive
organization we don't go attacking
people it is defensive and therefore
you know no one is threatening russia
russia has a right
absolute right to to have uh concerns
about wherever it is in the world about
its legitimacy uh sorry security
legitimacy and you know what it's going
to do to make sure it's safe in the same
way britain does but but that doesn't
mean to say
that it has an excuse to invade a
sovereign nation i understand that but
in these circumstances of ukraine is now
in a powerless position
and it's not clear that anybody's going
to help it i mean president biden has
ruled out sending u.s forces to defend
ukraine i assume that we do the same
secretary of state
well you're right in observing nate you
know ukraine is not a member of nato so
it wouldn't trigger an article 5 if
anyone would invade it and it would be
the consequence of invading it would
absolutely be
in the lap of the russian government who
would have made the decision to
uh you know
invade a sovereign nation and there you
know the history is littered with the
consequences of those sort of uh issues
but yeah i mean you're right i mean it's
a fact it's not a member of nato so it
is highly unlikely that anyone is going
to send uh troops into ukraine to
challenge russia uh in in that in
scenario i think that's been clear we
shouldn't kid people on that we would
and the ukrainians are aware of that
so they're on their own
well we we've helped you know we can all
help with capacity building but to some
extent ukraine is not in nato
and that's why we are doing the best you
know diplomatically globally to say to
president putin look don't do this you
know really don't do this if you have
worries about your security let's talk
and you know the prime minister spoke
this week and a number of world leaders
have spoken to president putin don't do
this because there will be consequences
but also because this is not how to
solve your security concerns um but but
that's why i reference you back to the
july letter or sorry article written by
president putin because that's not
really what his article's about it's not
really about nato at all it's about a
vision that ukraine really belongs to
mother russia and
the russian people um ethnic nationalism
effectively
and that has very interesting
consequences not just for ukraine but
for other parts of europe
where if that is a justification in the
mind of the president of russia we have
to ask ourselves
you know what does that mean for other
security and it would certainly raise
challenges for other nato nations nato
nations who would say well what about us
i mean if you are in estonia right now
or latvia
or even where i was in the high north in
sweden the other day not at nato country
they they feel that ripple
which is why there is a movement in
sweden for the first time to join nato
we'll see where that goes
but what have we done to help ukraine
defend itself so over the last few years
we have set up something called orbital
where we've trained over twenty thousand
uh ukrainian uh troops in being able to
be better troops and better defend their
country we've exercised together on
interoperability uh you know we we sent
uh a regiment of 16 hour salt brigade
did an exercise last year we have a
series of international exercises the
americans and
other nations even sweden has been in
ukraine helping capacity build their
forces we've not sold them guns though
have we we haven't we haven't yet uh
gone into the space of lethal aid the
united states has
provided them with substantial amounts
of anti-tank missiles that's
that's been public knowledge the
americans haven't hidden lethal aid at
all they've made it very clear helping a
country help itself er and defend itself
and we are constantly exploring all the
options not only as united kingdom but
also as the wider you know international
community i i chair in nato something
called the quint which is the uk
and a number of other nations canada for
example uh about our uk concern so we've
helped russia uh we've helped our
ukrainian capacity building we haven't
put bases in ukraine that's a falsehood
peddled from the kremlin there's no nato
base in ukraine we have um
we've all all of us internationally
exercise freedom of navigation in the
black sea
and we have you know signed into
agreement a number of potential
equipment sales to ukraine in the future
but but fundamentally we've helped them
help themselves
we've assisted where we can and where we
can expose what we would say is you know
destabilizing or sub-threshold uh
activities by another state including
russia then we've done that but i think
it's important
if the worst comes to the worst and
there's an outright invasion and as you
say we don't know capabilities there but
we don't know if uh if the intention is
there or if more complicated ways that
we know how the russians can put these
forces in they're not really forces they
don't wear badges but they can cause
they've done that in eastern ukraine
already
would we be prepared to cut russia off
from the swift international banking
system because that's the most effective
financial sanction we have and it would
cause moscow
serious problems
well i certainly think we would be clear
and determined across the international
community to put in severe economic
sanctions i think that's been already uh
trailed by both the g7 and the foreign
secretary what those actual sanctions
are obviously i think would be taken
closer to time depending on the severity
depending on what actually happens but
you are right to observe that something
like cutting off the swift would be very
very serious for russia's economy there
are other measures as well
and you know i'm i'm not a
international finance expert and uh in
that part of the government but but
certainly there are definitely deep and
serious and long-lasting economic
sanctions that could be taken uh i think
as we know with sanctions you have to do
it as an international effort you can't
so you know you might be of the united
states to do things you know actually
but to everyone else we have to do it uh
internationally
and i think there would be that
discussion to come and i i'm not going
to speculate on each individual uh
measures uh andrew because
you get into that line but but you are
right to make that observance and that
could cause significant issues the other
one is like nordstrom 2. uh you know if
europe continues to buy gas and
significant amounts from russia uh aft
if if they have invaded ukraine what
would that say about
the west resolve and the one person who
would like to see
weaker resolve is obviously uh in the
occupants in
the kremlin et cetera
let me take you to the other side of the
world now
australia's defense minister your
opposite number has said it is quote
inconceivable that australia would not
help the us defend taiwan if it was
attacked
does the same go for britain
well i think that britain's line is we
know we recognize the
the claim on taiwan but we also
recognize that that should be done
through a proper diplomatic and not a
military means uh would we help protect
it well i think i think you know i can't
give you that answer at the moment
andrew because i think you know that
would be for a wider government
discussion it's speculation we know
china's ambition is publicly stated to
unify
uh taiwan to mainland china as a as a
single entity one country um
and i think we'd have to cross that at
the time i don't think saying what we
would or wouldn't do
uh would uh help right now but i think
we've been very clear with china and
everyone else about you know respecting
uh those rules that's why we were so
upset about the hong kong issue where
you know the the one country two systems
also applied to taiwan that was quite an
important part and it it's very clear
that the one country two systems has
been junked when it comes to hong kong
and what does that read across taiwan
and we have expressed our displeasure
and we will maintain
uh uh protecting effectively taiwan from
uh aggression um because we think the
solution through that is for diplomatic
means
but the signature
foreign policy and defense
achievement of this government so far
has been the orcas agreement the pacific
pact with britain america and australia
and
the americans have made it clear and
president biden has made it clear that
they they will stand by
taiwan the australians have made it
clear they will stand by
america in doing that so given that
we're a crucial part of
this major pact
why can't we say the same well i think
first of all orcas was about helping
australia defend itself
uh it you know and with its partners it
wasn't
linked to taiwan it was actually linked
to australia wanted a strategic
capability
to keep at bay and keep at distance
adversaries in the pacific and i think
you know a diesel electric submarine
which they were currently about in the
process of buying
gives you very little range
and in a pacific where the surveillance
levels of you know isr in surveillance
and reconnaissance capabilities of the
of china for example are formidable you
are not going to be able to keep your
adversary second guessing or at a
distance in a diesel submarine that will
have to break the water from time to
time so fundamentally this was a pack
about strengthening australia's defense
and resilience and it was natural that
they used uk us nuclear secrets in the
propulsion of these submarines uh
because it's a five-eyes partner but it
was about more than that wasn't a
secretary of state it was symbolic of
britain almost in a sense
re-entering the pacific
he was playing a more prominent role in
the pacific with our allies uh with
japan
uh our aircraft carriers using
our allies for perimeter defense it was
much more than just about submarines
indeed the cortisols to the tree you
know a lot more than i will about them
they've got a lot about artificial
intelligence and robotics and building
up britain's role with the americans
there that's part of the purpose of it
isn't it
yeah that is i mean
britain is a strategic partner with a
number of countries we we like to think
of ourselves as having global reach we
have some unique capabilities and
australia as a like-minded
shares the same values partner in that
part of the world needs as much support
and building of resilience as possible
i think i think my point was it's not
just about taiwan this was much more
about reinforcing our values being
present alongside uh countries in the
pacific who hold those values
and also uh you know being able to
reflect the the simple reality is that
we are more global than ever you know
when we often have the debate about
isolationists you know this is not 1921
or the woodrow wilson or whatever it was
era
everything is connected i mean the
lesson of afghanistan is
it's connected what you do in
afghanistan is is heard in the pacific
and it's heard in the middle east um and
and it matters and
no no global country
should think that it can withdraw in a
way it might have been able to do a
hundred years ago you you you raised the
middle east just a couple more topics
because i know you're busy we need to
let you go
uh
the head of mossad israel's uh
intelligence services was in washington
a couple of days ago
both the us and israel are now
estimating that iran
is maybe only two to three weeks away
from the ability to assemble a nuclear
bomb its enrichment programs in 60
when you get to that level it's not that
difficult to get to the 90 you need to
make a bowl
is that our assessment too is it that
close
uh well i can't uh talk about our
assessments on that there would be
intelligence assessment on this andrew
but what i could say is uh that without
the jcpo a kicking back in
and the guaranteed uh you know three
plus three nations engaging fully
and anchoring iran to its commitment
which was a cap on enrichment levels we
face the very worrying prospect of
action by other other countries and you
talk about israel
but you also talk about you know there's
always the growing friction between iran
and saudi arabia that should always
worry us as well
and
you know that that as you rightly point
out when you get above an enrichment
level that goes way beyond the need for
civilian i mean a civilian nuclear power
station runs on i think about three
percent enriched uranium you start
getting above 20 percent enriched uh the
breakout time to fully enriched is uh
very very quick and i i i think you know
i don't know exactly what 2022 holds but
your observation and your reading back
of what the mossad
chief said in washington should make us
all redouble our efforts to bring iran
into a compliance space with the u.n and
and the areas around that nuclear treaty
and the you know the additional
protocols that while they haven't signed
up to
would give us all a sense of
confidence that it's not going to run
away from itself but yeah i think you're
right to worry that the nature of this
iranian regime is not only expanded
destabilizing
activity in the region
and remember we lost a british security
guard on a ship recently was hit by an
iranian cruise missile we've seen
constant supply of the houthis we've
seen the use of made weapons into iraq
against
either nato bases or indeed others
that nature of the regime coupled with
lack of compliance with the jcpo a would
lead it should lead us all to worry
about what is 2022 in the security of
the region final question to you
secretary of state
the military is being used to ramp up
the vaccination campaign again
earlier this month it was used to bring
power back to people after that terrible
storm
during the last few months the military
has provided ambulance drivers and
tanker drivers i think
we the spectator the british people are
immensely proud of what our armed
services have been doing during the
fight against uh covet
but i think a lot of our
readers and our viewers are wondering
that if the government wants to use the
army the military is a kind of domestic
resilience corps which is fair enough
are you going to have to stop cutting
the numbers
well i think there will be lessons to
reflect from this whole uh
event of the pandemic i mean i read the
spectator article and and there was a
large part of it i agreed with um you
know the the the the biggest danger one
of the things i have to protect the
armed forces from is you know the use of
the armed forces was always the last
resort right we you know we only did it
when the the firefighters went on strike
or the ambulance after a long period of
time
and it was critical to the dust men were
on strike in glasgow
[Laughter]
that's quite a regular occurrence i
suspect i mean i think i think i think
the um
and
what's happened is covid is a one-off
you know every
100 years type pandemic and a proper
national crisis and no one begrudges at
least all i the use of our armed forces
to assist the country in getting through
that but as we exit kovid over hopefully
in 2022
my job will be to reassert that we are
the last resort not the first resort and
if you are the scottish first minister
with significant funding for your health
service or your education service or the
welsh
first minister or indeed some of my
colleagues in whitehall
then you know it's not our job if you
can't run your health service in
scotland nicholas sturgeon it is our job
to be there as the last resort wherever
you are in the united kingdom but
fundamentally when we're not in a
national crisis or a pandemic
you know we'll always be there to help
but fundamentally we are there to do our
defence tasks of protecting the nation
secretary of state thank you for your
time today here on spectator tv and a
very merry christmas to you
now to the royals it's been your
favorite subject on spectator tv so we
couldn't round off the year without
returning to it i'm going to pass over
to freddie gray who's joined now by rod
little rod looking back at uh the
spectator's greatest hits this year on
our website
um it's fair to say a large number of
them
uh have been about harry and megan there
seems to be an amazing amount of
interest in them
and particularly in pieces that are not
very favorable towards them including a
couple by you
why is it that people seem to
dislike them quite so strongly
because they're vacant vacuous
privileged and hypocritical i think that
sums it up rather neatly
and partly because of course they've
done a lot of damage i mean they've done
a lot of damage to the royal family
which
um
a majority of people in this country
still have some respect for certainly
some respect for the queen and
and sadly departed prince philip
and they have done untold damage to it
uh
more even than harry's mom did to it i
suspect when we come to
tot up all these reckonings at the end
of the day
but more than anything they are so
blatantly visible
sitting out there in a
californian mansion
with 18 lavatories
an untold number of which
have working b days
um
and lecturing the rest of us on the
need for equality
this kind of vacuous concept of equality
which is
always championed by
um
american left winners and doesn't
actually mean equality at all
and
the other thing obviously which is the
most
common thing often said of them
is how desperately they desire their
privacy
and tell us this
through various conduits
every day of the week
and sign deals with companies such as
netflix presumably in order to protect
their privacy even more through having
fly on the wall documentaries and so on
they are hypocrites of the most
outstanding order and the term
champagne socialists could have been
invented for them
well perhaps their their desire for
privacy might explain uh what's going on
with the spotify deal that they did for
a large number of millions
and they have only produced one episode
in a year and uh i'm sure like like me
you regularly check your spotify's feed
to see if they've if they've uploaded
another one but so far no
well they have a problem and so
obviously to the to the companies which
have employed them
and the problem is this
that
uh they are caught between a rock and a
hard place they have they have to for
the sake of their current brand reject
everything that the royal family stood
for
but without having the implementation of
the royal family they amount to nothing
there it's just a gingerish hair head
and his pushy misses jabbering
unless that unless that connection to
the royal family is kept there is no
reason whatsoever why anyone should want
to watch them
well they've they seem to be trying to
create a very americanized version of
the royal family for the american media
market do you think although it might
drive brits like you and me uh
a bit crazy or make us cross
uh americans actually are quite
receptive to that kind of thing
well except it's nothing to do with the
royal family uh
and celebrity dumb
and being a royal
are not similar
they're certainly not the same but
they're not even similar
they require different
qualities
celebrities
requires endless
self-publicity
and the endless emoting
on any one of a number of given issues
being a member of the royal family
requires precisely the opposite of that
it requires
diligence
uh dignity
reserve
um and selflessness all of which are
antithetical to the concept of the
celebrity so
they can't get away with this and my
prediction is that they won't get away
with this for very long because they
will cease to be seen as anything
of any importance because that
connection with the royal family has
been broken but do you think it's partly
the royal family's fault for before
megan came along um i mean for decades
now the royal family has danced with the
world of celebrity and and
through the through the medium of the
tabloids it's it's flirted with pr and
and promotion and and publicity
it hasn't done so anywhere in the
anywhere in the league of what harry and
megan have gone up to
it is true that the queen has sometimes
been dragged screaming towards the pr
people
all of which began i think
recently with with uh with the advent of
tony blair
in downing street
um and perhaps they have gone down that
route too far
uh and of course harry and megan are the
royal family's only problems you know
there's the magnificent figure of andrew
lumbering around in the background as
well
so it's not been a good
year for the royal family and you might
argue it's not been a very good decade
for the royal family uh and you do get
the suspicion
that this whole thing is rather coming
apart at the same time well the
suspicion seems to be that um
once the queen goes and uh she can't
live for much longer um
the uh
the things will fall apart quite quickly
because it's been the queen's reserve
and her unwillingness to
engage in pr something prince charles
has engaged with a bit more that that
has kept the royal family the show on
the road
yeah i think that's exactly it and of
course the passing of the duke of
edinburgh was
was a terrible thing uh i mean a tragedy
obviously for the queen and for the duke
of edinburgh i suppose uh but a tragedy
also for the institution
of the royal family because the two of
them personified that selflessness that
uh that dedication to duty which is
meant to come with being a modern royal
there are a few glimmerings of hope
uh in
[Music]
william and kate
who
are beginning to show that same sort of
decency and reserve i just wish they'd
stop talking about mental illness every
30 seconds
it is difficult to find anyone in public
life in great britain who doesn't
immediately tell you how depressed they
are and seeking treatment for it i don't
know what's happened to this country um
but in the interim we have to put up
with charlie of course
how much better it would be if it were
anne
but instead it's charlie um
and i dare say there will be one or two
problems there he is also given to
making
uh fatuous political statements uh about
which he knows nafoll as anna might put
it
um so
we will just have to see it does seem i
mean
you look at the polls there is still
support for a monarchy
but it decreases and it decreases
uh gradually every year um and uh
you one one would expect that that would
continue to decrease
do you find i mean i imagine by instinct
uh i think i know by instinct you're not
a you're not a monarchist um
and i don't think your politics make you
uh
inclined to support the monarchy but do
you find that the sheer ghastliness of
harry and megan um
makes you fonder of the queen and the
idea of the the older idea of the
monarchy
oh yeah well two things yes i mean
obviously
harry and megan make me feel more kindly
disposed towards almost everybody else
on the planet
by comparison
absolutely ghastly individuals um that
that continual
whining um
but the other thing which makes me more
kind of disposed towards a queen and
their current royal family and even
prince charles
is a prospect
of what uttered dunderhead would be
elected president if we didn't have a
royal family and you can see it now
uh
it would be some worthy
from the left
uh it
it's quite possible that it would be
the famous actor david tennant or
or what's he called that sheen bloke uh
or eddie redmayne or baldrick from
blackadder you know and
that's why we have a queen so that we
don't have to put up with someone like
that
well i think we'll end it there rod on
that cheery note happy christmas
thanks freddie
the christmas season hasn't been normal
for two years running but should we be
counting our blessings in our christmas
issue peter hitchens writes about
spending the festive period in the ussr
with its spluttering vehicles gangster
haunted markets and the brown slush of
soviet modernity
peter is here to tell cindy all about it
alongside robert service a biographer of
lenin stalin and trotsky and an oxford
and stanford fellow
so peter you've written a wonderful
piece for the christmas issue this year
talking about your first christmas spent
in the ussr in 1990 and also the last
christmas at the uss arsenal can you
tell us about your experience
well we had to try and make something of
it we were there living in in moscow i
was correspondent
time i arrived in the city in in june
and was living illegally in a
extraordinary flat
which belonged to the communist party
central committee
with the breifner family on the other
side of the courtyard
but we really
were deprived of an awful lot of things
that you would normally expected at
christmas time we couldn't
we we didn't particularly want to import
british type food and stuff like that we
were trying to live as far as possible
as if we were genuinely living there
and
all this was mainly down to mrs hitchens
who went out and bought all these
astonishing things for us to eat
including the ingredients of an entirely
soviet christmas pudding uh from all the
then parts of the of the soviet empire
and the most marvelous goose uh which
she found she bought from an old woman
sitting on a corner from whom she could
probably also have bought a bag of magic
beans if she'd asked nicely and that the
resulting christmas dinner though it was
quite complicated eating it because
christmas day
uh the western christmas day in moscow
was not at all any kind of feast day and
the the
the congress of people's deputies was
busy meeting in the kremlin and all
kinds of news was happening uh was the
most extraordinary christmas dinner
we've ever had and probably the best
so i thought it would be nice to recount
how in the middle of all this uh turmoil
which there was a lot of
we managed to have for a few brief hours
something approaching christmas
in that extremely
uh intimidating and enormous thrilling
but rather frightening city
it sounds like mrs hitchens very much
saved the occasion there peter but your
seven-year-old daughter didn't seem to
enjoy it as much you say
she lost her trust in santa claus that
yeah well she was a bit disappointed
because she put down the usual list of
stuff and i think she she probably
thought being as how we were in a cold
snowy place it would get
get there quicker and more reliably but
the the presents when she opened them
all had this sort of slightly 1930s look
funny colored things with dangerous
corners and lumps on them because mr
sitchins had again gone out to the
extraordinary jet ski mirror the
children's world department store which
in those days stood right next to the
kgb headquarters and bought what she
could but it didn't look like anything
she'd asked for so she immediately
realized that uh that father christmas
had let her down quite badly and
obviously this was a blow
but she had put up with all that kind of
thing anyway so it was all part of her
growing up that's brilliant um and
robert um you were there in 1973 for
christmas for student exchange so
presumably you didn't have a very
resourceful wife to help you make the
day go well i mean how was it for you
well i was a bachelor
i was in a student hostel in leningrad
and christmas wasn't even recognized
very publicly by the
uh soviet authorities in that period
and
it was grim yeah it was a grim time it
was a grim day for a person who thought
it was christmas day to go out on the
street
and
uh not be greeted by someone or not
being
able to greet someone who knew it was
christmas so all of my colleagues
had uh
had gone to moscow for christmas
because i got there not having a visa
until the last moment because i was
studying
lenin
and
so i was marooned there and feeling
pretty sorry for myself
so what did you end up doing all day
i went i i booked up
god it was it was really clunky in those
days
to get a
telephone call back to the uk you had to
book it
a month sorry a week beforehand and go
to a
telephone kiosk
bank
in the center of the city
where you would
have a
20-minute slot
to talk to your family or
you have to pay for it and so on uh it
was all very
it was like going into a hospital
not a very good hospital at that
did you i i assume you had some
cockroaches for company i mean the kind
of place you
put up
they always supplied plenty of
cockroaches in the soviet union for and
rats as well if you
[Music]
you have cockroaches in there
the cockroaches in the hotels
did you ever get kicked out of hotels
because they had a cockroach day and you
the the cockroaches would be fumigated
and then you'd be allowed in
that i had some very weird hotel
experiences in the soviet union but that
wasn't one of them
the the best was of being was was
discovering that my assistant had been
rung up all through the night on the
hour every hour by someone from the kgb
posing as a prostitute offering her
services to my female assistant and
she'd said to her in her perfect rush
and look you're ringing the wrong room
it's we've swapped rooms it's my boss
you want a proposition and the woman
said no no no these are my orders i have
to ring this number all night
so she got it well that was that was the
weirdest hotel but uh but never a no
cockroach day plenty of multiple
cockroach days but never a day when they
they claim to be getting them out
uh and rats as well i mean it was it was
a lot of squalor uh but we were we were
fantastically spared from most of this
because of this extraordinary place we
lived in it it was uh
marvelous of
14-foot ceilings and oak parquet floors
and chandeliers because it we've got it
uh from a member of the nemanjura in an
illegal let and the block committee had
come around to complain that we were
there and then when they'd seen the
children they'd done that thing which
russians do when they see children and
god completely soft heart and said okay
you can stay
but
that's that's how he managed to hold on
to it but so we were spared an awful lot
of the horrors of soviet life while we
lived in that place it was one of the
nicest places i've ever lived actually
lovely views river one side kremlin up
to the university the other and uh i'd
say the whole the feeling of being in
moscow very powerful the really big
event
was new year's eve when
leonid brezhnev
the general secretary of the party gave
um
gave his annual
speech
and he
absolutely
ceaselessly
uh burbled on it seemed and and and it
was the the first time that the
soviet
students in the same hostel
started to show some sort of
tittering disrespect for their great uh
their great leader it was so
embarrassing because he couldn't he
couldn't even read his own speech and
this was in
uh 1973 this was nine years before he
died so
he was already in a bad way
yeah he was he was a figure of fun for a
long time it was a thing called soviet
rock where people would play the the 33
rpm
records of his speeches and they pushed
them forward with their fingers to the
applause
uh and it was a great joke but it was uh
it was a long and and tragic period but
he he was gone by the time we were
living in the block but his family was
still there we couldn't park our car on
the on that side of the courtyard
because all these ferocious grandmas
would come out and drive you away if you
came too close the andropov family also
was still there it was uh it was it was
marvelously privileged and you didn't
have any trouble with crime
well peter actually you know because of
the year that you were there what was
that like as the ussr was disintegrating
around you did it feel like that at the
time um and were you protected from the
elements of the politics side of things
we we didn't know it was going to end so
soon
i mean i'd gone there obviously to
witness the end of it and to see what
happened that was the whole idea but
we didn't know how quickly it would come
and we didn't know how it would come and
a lot of very dark things happened after
that christmas anyway a few days later
after christmas i was in vilnius when
the kgb went mad and started massacring
people and and then of course yanath the
awful drunk who had who'd become vice
president during that christmas uh was
the leader of the putch
which happened in august and i was there
in the same block in august when the
tanks came down the street that we
didn't know how it was going to it was
completely thrilling uh it was quite
frightening but in a sort of controlled
way you felt
although you were right on the edges of
european civilization you didn't really
know what sort of government it was it
wasn't that totally alarming thing you
can get in in countries where there is
utter chaos you felt that deep down
underneath
there was a desire for order of some
kind and that you were you were
fundamentally safe i don't think i would
have been able to take children there
otherwise but it was thrilling
exhilarating terrifying uh and i
wouldn't have missed it for the world
robert you were there that year too in
december what was that like would you
agree with peter's announcers
i do indeed i mean it
for
soviet watchers
it was
thrilling yeah and frightening
uh
at the same time a little
uh memory comes back to me now of going
into one of these big
stores that they had in in
uh
central moscow
in december
1990
and it was a dairy supermarket
and there were
15 or so smartly dressed
uh young women standing behind the
counters
and in this dairy supermarket there was
absolutely not even a half liter of milk
wow and i remember thinking then this
can't
this
this mighty soviet state with all of its
nuclear weapons with all of its
pretensions to summit
uh diplomacy it it
it can't last it must be soon on its
knees uh it was a really dramatic moment
for me i remember that i could buy a
little packet of tea in the dairy
supermarket where there's no butter no
yogurt
no milk
no all that stuff all that stuff you had
you
if you go around the back to the to the
the black the
children you've recorded the black exit
you you you would have been able to buy
that stuff or of course do what we did
which was we we
this is without resorting to hard
currency uh if you're paying pay over
the odds and rubles there were very good
markets where as i say we bought the
fantastic ingredients for the christmas
pudding and the wonderful
dried fruits coming up from by the
caspian sea because they were in the
center of this this great empire people
would struggle up
uh with suitcases full of raisins and
whatever it was and sell them for a tiny
profit but people there were
fantastically elaborate black market
systems a friend of mine used to swap
vodka which she bought in moscow for
chickens which a friend of hers provided
from riga and she'd put them on the
overnight sleeper and
with a with a fee to the sleeper
attendant and that's how she got her
chickens that's how people were getting
things the shops it's true had nothing
in them but it what was amazing was how
people survived even so
of course the system was as you rightly
said collapsing but
the funny thing was in moscow
particularly
there were if you had any kind of money
or contacts you could
get your way around a lot of it and the
back exit was crucial to all these
things as well
and robert um you and peter have both
hinted at this but the soviet state was
not exactly naturally friendly to the
idea of christmas um can you tell us
about the ways in which um you know the
ussr tried to eradicate these traditions
um throughout its regime
yeah well right from the start it was a
militant
atheistic state so they wanted rid of
religion and they wanted rid of
uh christmas so
uh they
found it impossible to do that i think
they did a survey of the red army
in the second world war 20 years
later and they found that half the
soldiers still believed in god
so
it wasn't so easy to get rid of
christian or muslim or jewish
belief
so what they
tended to do was to
have their own ceremonies have their own
rituals and they had one
for grandad frost instead of santa claus
actually lenin had his own christmas
tree you know
uh came from um
a lutheran background
originally so he
his family had the sort of german idea
like the british now have
of of the christmas tree
but they never got rid of
never succeeded in getting rid of um
the great religious faiths and and it
was
in 1990 going back in the late 80s and
early 90s that that the soviet
authorities finally said
we must have some
degree of religious tolerance and
garbage off
among his
um
achievements was to impose this on on
a communist party whose members have
been brought up to
to to enhance all all all metaphysical
uh magic as it was called um
so it was a huge huge um huge change
from say 1973
when the the churches were locked up
they were dank they were dreary and
usually it was only old women who were
creeping into them
because they had nothing to lose
young people who did so had everything
to lose they had their whole careers to
lose well it sounds like an incredibly
unique um experience for for you both to
have had considering that the ussr is no
longer here um peter and robert thank
you so much for joining spectator tv
thank you all
and now to finish off the show cindy
spoke to our contributors phillip
henscher and ascendant max stonegram
about their books of the year
so philip just start with
for the magazine you give us a few books
of the year for you from a translation
of beowulf to a memoir by amateur sen
can we push you what was your favorite
amongst the ones that you chose and why
i think that my favorite was paula burns
life of the novelist barbara pym and bob
is very kind of um suburban quiet comedy
sort of writer and paul
paula dug up some extraordinary
information about barbara perry
including the fact that she was really
quite a committed supporter of the nazis
in the 1930s something that
when i told people she discovered almost
everybody i told took it as a as a joke
it couldn't possibly be true but it's
beautifully written and it really does a
wonderful novelist proud i think
and
ascendo what about for you
my utter favorite i think um i i also
love the barber i also love the barber
frame i didn't actually choose it in my
my three i chose here um but i i'm
happened to be going to oxford this week
and i will look in the gutter in banbury
road to see if i can find that nazi
brooch that she dropped in the gutted
remember in 1934
um belonging to the nazi boyfriend so i
thought that was a marvelous one of the
great images of the year was the drop
nazi brooch from barbara pym
um i think my i i did philip and i both
loved the jane ridley george v which
which is a superb royal biography so
readable and
wry and witty and so charming about this
rather
ordinary man who became a great king
well that's really interesting because
he's obviously got this reputation for
being incredibly boring but it is
interesting that both of you chose that
book do you develop do you think like
she may manage to make him sound
interesting or was there was he a bit
maligned by being seen as boring i think
he is maligned as being seen as as
boring but um he's actually george v and
queen mary's wife they've been very
lucky in their biographers actually um
from you know right really right from
the the beginning and i think it is the
the fascination of this slightly kind of
cryptic mysterious character this idea
of this essentially very shy couple
being forced to
you know put on the uniform and parade
in front of the the empire um i i'm very
i'm very touched by george v character i
think he was a a wonderful king and i
think how what a good king he was is
shown by the fact that it all came very
very close to falling apart the second
he stepped down
i also thought it was interesting that
both you and philip chose uh
non-fictions mainly um was there a
reason for not choosing more fictions in
your in your list
for me the simple reason is i'm a
non-fiction reviewer so i read far far
more nonfiction this year than i did
fiction the one of the funerals i did
read was the one that you chose philip
and the casio ishiguro which i thought
was fantastic um just such a master
masterful bit of fiction so so sort of
taught and so
so controlled in its little tiny worlds
that the vision of the this
ai roboty thing looking out of its shop
window at the beginning was just
enchanting
and and and and so i thought i applauded
that choice
and that's clara in the sun yes that's
right clara and the sun
yeah and philip for you you know you say
that um
uh you find it hard to get excited about
fiction this year
yeah
i don't know what i don't know what
happened um let us turn our eyes away in
sorrow and and regret from the book of
shortlist which you know was really
so dismal but there were good they were
good novels published this year i think
i would really recommend coulson
whitehead's harlem shuffle i think he's
a wonderful novelist i also quite like
the jonathan franson um
slightly pathetically called crossroads
to an english readership um
but it's certainly true that the i don't
know the fiction publishing industry in
the prize
prize awarding
industry
they just seem to have their eyes on
some very
curious books i think and a lot of books
that were praised in a very kind of
solemn way this uh this year um
just uh just seemed completely dismal to
me there was a new sally new novel by
sally rooney and i loved her first two
novels this one um i couldn't not only
could i have not finished it but i've
never i didn't meet anybody else who
finished it at all it was
a sad it's a bit of a sad case i hope
she gets back to form in her next
next novel
um yes i love you i loved your article
in the in the spectator about your about
that booker list and how every single
one somehow is depressing dreary and
somehow disappointing and so solemn
where's the fun with the where's the wit
and the fun and the enjoyment of of
novels and and can't they allow that to
be a big criteria
in in how they choose them
i i never felt i never felt as though
i'd earned my fear as a reviewer so so
thoroughly as reading those six novels
and after i'd after i'd read them i went
back and read an old novel by kingsley
amis and i just thought oh here's
someone who doesn't expect you to to be
applauded for these sanctimonious
opinions you know you're allowed to
disagree with this novel it's i i really
miss it but it's there are there are
good novels out there yeah now philip
obviously last year was a bit difficult
for the publishing industry given the
repeated lockdowns and what that did to
deadlines do you think that's bounced
back now and for readers and authors
actually lockdown has been a good time
to get inspiration or to consume more
books or do you think that's not the
case
i think it probably helped some help
consumers and
and certainly
i i found myself reading a lot more and
digging back into um into classic
literature
reading
whole authors backlist with a lot of
pleasure
i know this i'm talking to to writers
now
uh about what it was like writing in
um during covid
obviously you know anybody who
who needed uh research in libraries that
was uh that was going to be hopeless
that put a lot of
strain on people i think problems
possibly
less
understood is how difficult it was for a
lot of um novelists and writers of
affection um and
i you know i was supposed to be writing
a novel when when lockdown started and
it just came to an end you know i just
couldn't go on with it and i think that
for a lot of writers of
fiction
you do need a kind of steady drip of
overheard humanity you need those
overheard conversations on buses you
need to listen to
people talking and that that went and
suddenly you know i i had i don't want
to call it a writer's block it just
didn't didn't seem as though there was
anything there to be
to be written um but it certainly
stopped and didn't come back until um
lockdown uh
finished but you know in the you know on
the on the plus side you know i read
i read every single novel by john le
carre and every single novel by ivy cops
and burned it so that's not that's not
such a bad thing
you've used it much more productively
than i have
essendo what about you have you gone
back to old books that you've not read
or re-read old books and because of
lockdown i mean pg woodhouse always
there these are these awful moments um i
i do i'm a writer i'm a writer i write
in cafes so when cafes were closed i
made it very hard cause i can't write in
my own boring little home space so
that's been another problem i think for
writers um yes um i i definitely went
back to
my lovely classic jane jane austin and
fiji woodhouse
at all times so to fall back on they've
been such a godsend
and philip looking forward to next year
what are some of the things that you're
excited about writers or books that are
coming out well uh one um
one non-fiction and one fiction the the
non-fiction is the
uh the last volume of chips shannon's
diaries which was i mean the first two
volumes this year uh edited by simon
heffer the first complete version uh was
such a sort of
low-level pleasure really you could just
pick it up and read for five pages and
just chips the
1920s and 1930s um social climber just
being absolutely appalling on the page
it was very enjoyable the uh the fiction
that i really wanted to uh to recommend
is a novelist that i adore and i don't
think she's that well known in this
country it's the sri lankan uh
australian novelist michelle de kretzer
and i think i really think she's the
wittiest novelist going the sentence is
just sheer joy and the novel that she's
got coming out in january it's called
scary monsters and it's a it's a family
story it's about the
impact of
of of immigration long long before
it's just so beautifully told so riley
funny it's um i adore it i love all her
books but this is a real a real treat
thank you so much philipp pensgen it's
in the maximum grain
thanks again all
and that's it for this week and for the
christmas season if you enjoyed this
episode don't forget to subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode thanks
for watching and do join us again in the
new year
[Music]
you